if you've been on social media at all
over the past few days then you know
every single person on your entire
timeline has expressed support for black
lives matter not just support for black
people I've everybody supports black
people nobody thinks black lives don't
matter but specifically for this
organization a radical leftist
organization called black lives matter
and if anybody has not expressed support
for black lives matter
probably they've faced some negative
consequences there's been a lot of
pressure to do this well friend of mine
who maybe you know from the internet
he's an author he's a podcaster he's the
host and author of rules for retrogrades
Timothy Gordon he spoke out against
black lives matter he contradicted the
leftist orthodoxy and he has been fired
from his job teaching at a Catholic
school a Catholic school because of that
and so now because tim has opposed this
radical leftist movement he is no longer
able to bring home a paycheck for his
wife and six children one of whom has
serious health problems in addition to
you know just just the normal
difficulties of raising a family Tim why
on earth would you speak up when you
know that these leftist goons are gonna
go out and try to destroy your life
what's up Mike thanks for having me on
why here's like Russell Westbrook says
men why not
because this is the time now is the time
for the new American right to rise up
you know embracing all races all colors
and all Creed's converting them this is
how much we love everybody black white
yellow brown from all different walks of
life we love you so much that we want to
convert you and make the face of America
Christian Christian Roman Catholic
that's that's what we do and this is the
time now more than ever we need brave
stalwarts we're willing to put it all on
the line and I thought why not me why
not you well one of the reasons why not
you is because the minute that you go
and you speak out then they target you
and they harass you I I've seen this
even conservative friends of mine are
basically going along with this because
they don't want to be attacked
there are store businesses in in Los
Angeles right now they've got
boards on the windows because they don't
want to be looted and they've got
graffiti on them I realized it wasn't
the rioters who sprayed the graffiti it
was the shop owners and then the
graffiti says we support black lives
matter minority-owned business please
don't attack us basically please don't
don't loot what is it that you said that
got you fired a couple things on Twitter
though the way one does never says just
one like Lay's chips BLM is a terror
organization the simple historical
statement of fact Mike that for the FBI
anyway the BLM is a B ie a black
identity extremist group and they copped
to that they responded to that FBI
designation in 2017
you know Catholic schools as we know our
absolute sufferers of the Stockholm
Syndrome I don't know the insanity of
Stockholm Syndrome the masochism right
and they've been taken out of stage by
this hostile culture and yet they seem
to be giving in to the to the hostile
leftist culture the hustles who want as
a stated goal Mike they want to shut out
of business all private schooling make
it illegal and they say on their webpage
they want to destroy the Western family
meaning the Christian nuclear family
structure in addition to being these
wannabe Jacobins
you know they're weak they're to the
jacobins and spray-painting my church
burning churches down murder arson
mayhem in the cities that they're
terrorists they're one of me but rope
spheres but Tim come on
you you know here you have been told
that even though right now there is
looting and rioting and murder and
destruction going on across the United
States and multiple cities that is
completely separate from the peaceful
protests that just happened to be going
on in exactly the same place at exactly
the same time for us density the same
reason totally different things come on
be fair I'll tell you what it's separate
from Mike it's separate altogether 100
point zero zero two do with George Floyd
that's what it's separate from the
peaceable protests are pre games right
it's it's daytime pre games you
arrest sometime when your some you know
filthy wannabe Jacobin we're waiting out
in the street and you know you're being
paid by George Soros front groups like
Anitha you know I'm sure I want I want
to pause there for a moment cuz because
the left is saying that this is a
conspiracy theory that George Soros is
just a boogeyman that he's funding these
groups you can actually look to the
founders of black lives matter you can
look at the organizations that they have
worked for that they're continuing to
work for in lead and you can track the
donations from George Soros is open
societies foundation this is not some
conspiracy theory you can actually track
the money of nonprofits have paper
trails and and anybody is free to look
at them amen thanks thanks for saying
that it I don't know why more outfits
aren't saying that loudly yeah 2016-2017
this safer bet for articulation was that
BLM is the terror organization
AG bar finally better late than never
declared an ephemeris organization but
until this nonsense over the last two
weeks BLM was well considered the safer
bet is a terror organization and also
for people who don't like that word they
so they they just are quibbling over
that word you've got to get down to what
terror means terrorism is when people
use violence against civilians to affect
political ends that's the most basic
definition of terrorism and does does
that mean that everybody who has used
the hashtag black lives matter supports
using violence to achieve political ends
no certainly not but does that mean that
a great many people who are right now
out demonstrating on behalf of BLM are
using violence against civilians to
achieve political ends yes absolutely
and I'll take it one step further Chris
Cuomo the other night on CNN this is the
brother of Andrew Cuomo governor of New
York
he's the Fredo of the Cuomo family he
went on television and he said show me
where it says that protests have to be
polite and peaceful and this is funny
because in the First Amendment of the
Constitution it says the people have the
right to peaceably assemble but
obviously Chris Cuomo has never read
that what Chris Cuomo is openly
advocating here is political violence
against civilians keith Ellison the
Attorney General in Minnesota
same thing he posed holding a pick a
copy of the ante feh handbook right
advocating this kind of political
violence so there's no doubt that this
is going on you said something that is
provocative sure but something that is
easily justifiable and you lose your job
for it luckily you have a platform I
mean people at least can listen to you
you can get this out there how many
other people who don't have a major
platform is this happening to around the
country
yeah well it's embolden 8 to do I I'd
like to think that without the platform
that I have I'd be have been willing to
do it as well I want to address the
first thing you've said about the tawdry
nominalism of not every single one of
the people who have ever uttered black
lives matter are you know
revolutionaries of course not right I
mean it you know black lives matter is a
terror organization is not racist just
because black is in the word to arouse
it just as the Irish Republican Army
doesn't call us to an anti Irish point
of view by saying this is a Marxist
organization it's that's a great moment
I want to I want to highlight that for a
second because that hadn't occurred to
me there's this people might not even
remember it these days but there's this
group the IRA a right and it was these
Irish terrorists who were setting off
bombs and things like that if you call
out and you say hey I don't support the
violence that's associated with the IRA
that doesn't make you an Irish ofoh but
that doesn't make you an anti Irish
racist but no one ever thought that
before there's something hyper sensitive
about the black issue in America and
it's time that we get over it if you're
a white man in the streets you are twice
statistically twice as likely as a black
man to be killed by a cop only nine
people in the last year nine unarmed
black men were killed by cops it's
well-well or McNugget and that's piece
in The Wall Street Journal she's done
great work and it was actually shocking
even to me because what we are told by
say LeBron James for instance is every
time a black man leaves his home he is
hunted down by this white supremacist
power structure and then I looked I said
how many unarmed black men were killed
by police last year and by the way
unarmed doesn't
not dangerous right unarmed doesn't mean
that the killing wasn't justified but
let's just use that because that's the
topic that there that's the the
measurement that ever ones using I
thought what is it nine thousand no nine
hundred no ninety no we're talking about
nine unarmed black men were killed by
cops cops of all races by the way and
one of those unarmed black men according
to Heather's excellent piece in Wall
Street Journal had a loaded gun in his
car during a car chase Tucker Carlson
went on and gave the stories of so many
of these people in the circumstances and
so it I mean this is something we should
all be happy about right there the this
is not happening the claims of black
lives matter are not true the
foundational claim a black lives matter
about Michael Brown being executed with
his hands up saying don't shoot that's
not true we know from multiple
eyewitnesses black eyewitnesses grand
jury multiple autopsies that he reached
for the cops gun and charged the cop
it's so it's just founded on lies it the
scourge that they're saying exists does
not exist and what's the practical
outcome what's what what is the effect
of those lies the effect of those lies
is now cities are burning to the ground
people's livelihoods are being destroyed
people are being actually killed and and
people's reputations are being ruined
and smeared including in your case
certainly yeah I'd love to talk about my
case some but I think it's really
important to stay broad at least for a
half-second more yeah
people revolutionaries from you know
terrorists revolutionaries like
Diocletian who also tried to force
Christians to their knees to worship him
instead of the crucifix in the Eucharist
they always have a of Politburo of
source with a brainwashing campaign they
do people not understand this Mike that
there since from Diocletian Nero - you
know robust fear to the the free masons
of the past
- tricking Obama man they always say
we're gonna do our terror well they
don't say that part it's the subtext on
the behaves of the low the my I mean
playing I always you know we look we've
got it we're doing something so good so
if we if we violate the law if we spy on
US citizens if we if we target people if
we if we killed
people even you know in the case of like
a robust beer or some you know it's the
line that's often attributed to Joseph
Stalin you can't make an omelet without
cracking a few eggs the the premise
being their end goals are so noble and
good
then it justifies all manner of evil in
the meantime it's a great line by the
way and I didn't know Soviets had
omelets but that's well that's one good
thing about the Soviets that you know I
mean it's it's real so before before we
get particularly we got a stay general
and just say do not be useful idiots do
not be a Ned Flanders Christians out
there we need to fight back this is
another thing I got in trouble for is
saying again it's it's equally non edgy
and banal right by the standards of my
Twitter accounts I can't believe I
survived this long to be honest with you
things that you say I think here you
know that that one pretty
middle-of-the-road right Osama bin Laden
is a terrorist it's good we all cheered
when he died it's like that's that is
not out there stuff I was not venturing
far out there on the branch it's not far
out there on the branch either I got
local media in my hometown a little
north of you yeah saying that I said you
know the police are being too restrained
they should fire upon these semi mythic
peaceful protesters as we already
discussed the daytime protest is
pre-gaming for the real organized event
the main event the marquee event the
night the nighttime mayhem in arson I
seen everywhere yeah which which was
just completely a Bic wa tiss and we've
all been told about the the elegant
structure of this the calculated
structure the the brick piles
strategically Lane the medics that BLM
and annsofi have out there field medics
helping people get patched up in you
know well in in well done reportage
right so it's really really important
for for people out there to know how
well organized this is and this also
includes the publicity campaign don't be
a useful idiot one of Lenin's idiots who
just says well they said they're doing
something good Planned Parenthood says
that it likes Parenthood no it's the
opposite of that all lives matter
right and cops black cops lives matter
black property owners lives matter
before we move off of
rules for retrogrades i just want to put
in there for the people now in my
hometown who are trying to get me as a
racist one of the 40 rules for
retrogrades
in my book co-author with my brother is
there is no room on the new tough
american christian right for racists
none
is this is the real key here because
there's so much information out there
there and there's so much disinformation
out there that for instance they you
know you you people are denying that
anti feh is an organized group now those
of us who've encountered an tyfa maybe
it's speaking events i've certainly had
my run-ins with them we know that it is
a very organized group so that's
happening on one hand they're denying
that they're organizing then on the
other there you know for instance there
was a pile of rocks that was in up in
sherman oaks and this was now being
attributed to an Tifa leaving them there
the only reason i know auntie if i
didn't leave them there is i've i've
driven by it a lot of time so i've seen
that particular pile of rocks for many
years now is that is then being pointed
to and saying we'll see this is more
evidence that it's all a conspiracy
theory
guess what i've also seen a pile of
antigua protesters organizing at
multiple events so that's not a
conspiracy either there's just so much
so much noise that's going on out there
and so when they went after you it
really bugged me personally because the
chart the things they're saying about
you you're racist you're bigoted it's
just absurd but i also had the privilege
of writing the foreword to one of your
books and it was a book called rules for
retrogrades and in it i mean it's i
think it's within the first 10 pages you
say that there is absolutely no quarter
on the right for bigots and and
specifically for racial bigots so it's
just if they did two seconds of google
search on you they'd know this isn't
true but that's not the point i don't
think they care about the truth i think
they want to ruin your life because you
stood up to them yes the i mean what can
i how can i say it better than that
propaganda works it works ten times out
of ten a hundred times out of a hundred
the point of propaganda is not
information but disinformation they
probably some of them have read my book
some some of them are lawyers in town
and basically in if we can go a little
more particular it's just old-fashioned
this
centers from the Catholic Church in
Catholic school the church gives quarter
to them the dioceses give quarter to
them and the the group of petitioners in
in Bakersfield California who got me
fired are nothing other than alums and
parents over the last 10 years at
Garcia's memorial who were dissidents
and never liked the Church's teachings
on abortion gay marriage contraception
and balked at it when I was teaching in
the classroom and that that's the
connection between the propaganda effort
seen commonly seen by the radical left
well and yeah the story yeah I wanna I
want to get into this this Catholic
aspect too because you know obviously I
not only are we both Catholic we've gone
to Mass together and but you speak much
more specifically about Catholic issues
right your your hyper focused on that
and you're teaching at a Catholic school
you were teaching at a Catholic school
right you are it you're as much your
being as honest as you possibly can be
about what you're saying about about
this sector of society and yet the
leftist popular culture just can't let
you be it's not like you were teaching
at a public school at a secular school
at Harvard or sent right you were
actually teaching to Catholics when they
say no no the Catholic school can't
teach Catholic things the the Catholic
school that could the conservative
speaker can't say conservative things
one one suggestion that has been brought
up in in the Christian world is the
Benedict option Rod Dreher has talked
about this that basically the culture is
becoming so hostile to not just
Catholics but but Protestants to Eastern
Orthodox Jews I mean really it's it's a
hostile to religious people generally
are we getting to the point where we
basically just have to give up the
culture and go live in the woods
somewhere no I Rod Dreher is a smart guy
but but he's wrong it only unless you
you seriously modify the Benedict option
is it correct what I'm advocating for is
a new American right retrogrades
Christian there's rule there's there's
room
for all all people but it's specifically
Christian more specifically its
functioning on the domestic basis of
Catholic ideas right natural rights and
natural law it really comes most
robustly from the Catholic tradition and
as you'd say here for our for our
Protestant viewers and even our even our
secular viewers that when when you go
and think about st. Thomas Aquinas and
natural law you know so much of the
language that we just talked about in
our American tradition the idea of
natural rights that were endowed by our
creator with certain rights does come
downstream from these sorts of ideas and
you wrote a book on this - sort of
reaching out and saying look you might
not be Catholic you might not or you
might not think you're Catholic but a
lot of the ideas that you hold dear
actually come from the Catholic
tradition yeah absolutely I don't want
to be too academic but the Jefferson and
Madison had Bell ermine mark who is a
Thomas
Catholic marked up in their libraries as
did John Locke and Algernon Sidney you
can't get the ideas of natural rights
and natural law from John Locke and
Algernon Sidney they had to get those
from the ultimate the enemy of their
arch enemy Robert filmer who wrote this
book Patriarca Robert filmer was
responding to Bell ermine and Bela means
really the ideological source of the
American Revolution ultimately it's
Thomas because all the great things
Thomas is the master of those who know
right and by the way a lot of people
don't know Thomas is the first expositor
in human history in a in advanced robust
philosophical treatise of the just right
to rebellion
it comes from Thomas before Bela and
Locke and Sidney just borrow from that
Aquinas is the one so and he
distinguishes Mike between sedition and
insurrection by the way meaning if it's
just law if you have natural law on your
side yeah you can even you can kill the
tyrant even Aquinas says first one to
ever say that however if it's on the
other side
sedition versus insurrection he says to
squash it he's a you know people
Christians need not be pacifists
weak-kneed Ned Flanders cowardly
pacifist which is what we allowed
ourselves to be and I feel it's too akin
to what Dreier's suggesting some more
man though he is no we don't need to be
weak Ned Flanders we might need to chunk
out a portion of the country for
ourselves in the in the near the
middling future that might be what we
need to do but it's not the same thing
as the Benedict option we are called the
fight to if we need be to defend our own
property if the police are told to stand
down
it's what the Christian does to be
strong there's room for everyone we love
everyone and we want to work together
the retrogrades the new American right
with all colors all Creed's of course
we'd like to convert them that's that's
the ultimate goal but that's not what
this is about this is political action
and we have to join arms with all the
peoples of goodwill and be tough it's
that's this is what the young people
want is toughness
I'm thinking maybe Montana you know when
I agree with you I want to be in the
culture I want to keep the fight up
maybe we need our own little chunk of
the country Montana looks pretty good
and I'm I'm only half joking because
I've been in LA during all of these
peaceful riots and I you know the very
wonderful like noble peaceful arson and
I've just been looking around and I said
when it when is LA gonna do something la
announces yesterday that their response
to the riots is they're gonna defund the
police by 150 million dollars I don't
know how much longer conservatives or
Christians or or any sort of normal
person can can remain in these kind of
leftist hotbeds as the cities are
burning to the ground I do want to get
specifically on what you're gonna do
because you know they've taken away your
livelihood you've got six kids one of
whom has very special needs you know it
needs a lot of attention care what are
you gonna do now that's let's brainstorm
this together me I got you you got a
good mind I got a good mind listener
know I mean I like you said I got a
platform which is which has been
burgeoning anyway had this worldwide
podcast with with dr. Taylor Marshall
then I went off on my own and it is
untoward remarkable timing because Mike
my eldest daughter Abby who you know you
were gonna come come see us when we were
staying yeah close to your neck of the
woods in the hospital she had a
humongous brain surgery that she's
recovering from two months ago and she's
mostly over recovery it's
amazing you know god is good god sees
you out the corner of his eye he really
really does but it's just great that I
got that incredibly large
hemispherectomy surgery done with on on
Insurance dime but the point is and for
people don't know what that means that
they removed like a portion of your of
your daughter's brain I mean this is a
very serious surgery yes it's it used to
be actually they take out the entire
hemisphere which is causing the
basically ceaseless seizures well I had
a B by the way in Rome Italy when I was
working on a PhD 12 years ago and we
left it behind when I went to law school
but and she's had nothing but seizures
since since we kicked this off we kicked
it back like I can down the road for 12
years but cuz it's scary yeah now it is
a hemispherectomy 's are mainly just dis
wiring the bad side of the brain which
which is causing the seizures but they
took out sizable chunks of the brain it
was really really traumatic and we were
living in our RV right near the hospital
there in Orange County for like three
weeks
it was it was a crazy time and when I
look back on it Garces Memorial you know
I would get emails from the school the
Garcias families praying for you that
you know you're part of the Garcia's
family Abby's like a niece and then and
then to capitulate to the left in such a
vile cowardly fashion throw you under
the bus and smear you is some kind of
bigot or yes it's really it's really
awful I mean I I am glad at least that
you've got this platform and you know
people people can go out and buy and
read your books catholic republic and
rules for retrogrades if you want to
read a foreword by yours truly
and you know listen to the show and
listen you know even to older episodes
of your other shows and shows with
Taylor Marshall they're really great
content I know there's also a GoFundMe
that was set up which raised a
considerable amount of money I don't
know how far it's gonna go with six kids
but you know I would direct people to
that as well how does they go fund me
going so the GoFundMe is going well as
we concern ourselves than not
financially the problem is this
viewpoint discrimination
non-governmental
you point discrimination which we've
been talking about all show long and
nuanced private sector version it has
far reach we've already had the account
put on hold like two or three times I've
seriously doubt that I'm ever gonna see
the money I think a lot of your viewers
have already been generous and dug into
the pocket to help thank you very much
if you get a refund on that you can go
to Timothy J Gordon com just my name
Timothy J Gordon com and if you feel so
inclined if you're still in the position
once you get that I think inevitable
refund because they're calling me a
racist then we have a donate button set
up there and I'd appreciate it a lot I I
want to keep making good content and I'd
like to do it full-time yeah you know I
mean every storm cloud has a silver
lining and and maybe it is the case that
this will give you the opportunity to
you know great more content you've got
really great and interesting things to
say and you know hopefully that there
there's not too much targeting and
distress I know they were trying to docs
you right I mean this there's a lot of
vitriol coming your way right now from
the radical left its ugly in this man
but I'll tell you one one thing I can I
can damn well take it and I think what
America needs right now is someone that
just looks it down and says like bring
it on man because it would be tough for
someone that that's not situated the way
I'm situated but it doesn't matter at a
certain point we're coming up to the
fourth of July at my weenie roast with
my friends for the last 10 years I look
him in the eyes and I say I'm serious
what do you think we're doing him in do
you think this is all about because
they're all good Christian and
Protestant Catholic whatever people of
peace generally speaking and it's fun
it's a nice holiday fireworks are great
you know weenie roasts are phenomenal
particularly if it's more like a steak
roast I mean that's not the point man
these were real men were no we're not
mythologizing them I mean the the the
genius that went into someone like a
James Wilson or a James Madison Thomas
Jefferson the genius behind their ideas
these were based red peeled political
geniuses who put their fortunes and
their honors and their lives on the line
and I'm sorry to say Mike I see none of
that I see none of it in America I see a
fat cowardly nation that I want I want
to inspire so it's just like men lead
lead from the front
like I don't care let it happen to me
let it happen unto me and maybe people
can be inspired by this is this is the
best you've got like Theoden of Rohan
said it's like this is this is all you
got like bring it man it's it's not
formal viewpoint discrimination yet they
haven't taken the First Amendment out of
the Constitution yet not yet I say bring
it up thickly they have sometimes but
not not officially at least true that's
right I you know it does it does remind
me of that idea that tough times make
tough men
or it just destroys society but it's
definitely one of those two things and
we look back and we say gosh you know if
only I could be like a Thomas Jefferson
if only I could be like an Alexander
Hamilton well you know now maybe you've
got the opportunity to prove yourself
there's there's an ancient Chinese curse
that I've heard before which is may you
live in interesting times and whisset
we're living through that right now and
it does give a lot of chaos and there's
a lot of misery and there's a lot of
hardship and there's a lot of people
trying to dodge you and ruin your life
but there's also a lot of opportunity
and maybe maybe as some people who still
have hope in the the American country
and the American tradition have said
maybe our best days really do lie ahead
but the only way out is going to be
through the only way out it's always
through and damn straight to all that
other stuff you said it's it's not fun
is it's kind of a second second and a
half third bad day in a row for me but I
mean it men from the heart of going
through something like this I'm not
exaggerating you Mike you know
Bakersfield's it looms small on the the
cosmopolitan landscape but it's one of
America's 50 largest cities they are all
the note local news stations are
painting me as the opposite of what I am
a racist and it's it's you just have to
look at it and laugh laughter is war and
use for the fight man and you should you
should take great solace because you
know whatever the media call you the
opposite is true so if the if the media
we're calling you like a really good
person then you should be worried
because then you really have to take a
look at your own character
that's so right if LeBron James thinks
you're a good person you gotta have a
look at the man in the mirror I'm asking
him to change his ways go have a look at
Tim Gordon Timothy J Gordon calm rules
for retrogrades podcast get the book
rules for retrogrades get the book
catholic republic maybe if you have a
couple nickels two going together in
your pocket head on over to that
GoFundMe page or two Timothy J Gordon
comm Tim man thanks for coming on I hope
you stay strong in the next few days
probably gonna be tough but hey the only
way out is through as we were as we were
saying thank you so much menu you can
all count on it stay strong everyone out
there uh rise alright Tim Gordon thanks
everybody
[Music]
[Music]